the PlayStation 5 is receiving welcomed
software and Hardware improvements a new
kind of Xbox controller exciting Pokemon
gen 9 details on today's Gamespot news
following an earlier beta test the
latest PlayStation 5 firmware update is
out now adding 1440 HDMI video output
and game lists AKA folders users can
check if their HDMI device can reach
1440p by choosing test 1440p output in
the screen and video option under system
settings for those playing a game with a
higher native resolution such as 4K Sony
said they may benefit from improved
anti-aliasing through super sampling
down to 1440p Output as for game lists
players can now create these in their
game library to help make organizing
games easier game lists can support up
to 100 games and users can have up to 15
lists players can select any game to add
to a list whether it be on a disk
digital or streaming a full list of the
new features of the PS5 firmware update
at the link in the description on the
hardware side YouTuber Austin Evans got
his hands on the new PlayStation 5 Mod
model that was discovered in the wild
last week upon opening it he discovered
that the motherboard is around two
inches smaller and that the SSD
inclusion no longer has a printed
circuit board through the entire length
of the device and has more exposed metal
which Evans believes will dissipate heat
more efficiently the cooling setup now
has an additional heat pipe and a
smaller heat sink with the entire build
now being around a pound lighter than
the original ps5's Hardware as for
tangible benefits Evans theorized that
this model will draw around 20 to 30
watts of power less during gaming
sessions but heat and noise output will
remain roughly the same so for everyone
that's been struggling to find a
PlayStation 5 over the last nearly two
years rest easy knowing that when you do
eventually pick one up it will likely be
an improved model if you ended up making
the Xbox series or as your console of
choice this generation Microsoft has a
great new accessory for you the Xbox
Elite Series 2 core model is a cheaper
version of Xbox's regular Elite Series 2
with fewer features priced at 130
dollars the controller has adjustable
tension thumbsticks a rubberized grip on
the handles and hair trigger locks
button mapping is also available through
the Xbox accessories app just like it is
for the regular model while the core
controller doesn't come with the back
pedals alternate d-pad and thumbsticks
and charging case that the regular Elite
controller does those items can be
picked up as a part of a complete
component pack for sixty dollars which
would actually ultimately make it more
costly and total than the normal Elite
Series 2 which Microsoft currently sells
for 155 dollars still if you're looking
for an additional Elite controller or
wish to replace yours because there's an
unsettling rattling around in the
chassis like mine because you maybe
dropped it one too many times
the court is a slightly less expensive
option that will work with all your
current Elite accessories but wait don't
rush to pick up the core yet as
Microsoft also teased that the Elite
Series 2 controller will be coming to
Xbox Design Lab this holiday allowing
you to customize it with a variety of
colors Nintendo released a new Pokemon
scarlet and violet trailer today which
showed off the three separate Adventures
that make up the game's campaigns in
addition to the gym and Pokemon League
quest line the player will take on team
star this generation's bothersome group
of nerdwells the third and final
storyline will partner you up with a
fellow classmate Arvin in search of rare
cooking ingredients called herbal
mystica playing into the treasure hunt
theme of the games three new Pokemon
were also introduced in the trailer
starting with the crab-like cloth cloth
presented the new Titan mechanic which
seems to operate like the alpha Pokemon
of Pokemon Legends Arceus the other two
new Pokemon will be exclusive to one of
the two versions of the new game
Scarlet's exclusive is amarouge a dual
fire and psychic type Pokemon that draws
its power from the armor it's wearing
Sarah ledge a fire and Ghost type
Pokemon that uses blades made of both
fire and ghost power will be exclusive
to Violet while not shown off during the
trailer a new page on the scarlet and
violet website shows off The Game's new
let's go feature while exploring the
world you will be able to deploy one of
your Pokemon to roam separately for you
with it able to discover and recover
items it can also automatically battle
wild Pokemon which you can stand by and
witness or have occur while you're doing
something else entirely sounds great
until your Pokemon Auto chaos shiny
and that's it for today's Gamespot news
are you picking up a new core controller
or waiting for Xbox Design Lab what
about those new Pokemon details do those
do anything for you let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow on Gamespot news
[Music]